everybody stick behind me
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Michael
Bay finally premiered the Transformers 4
trailer during the Super Bowl and
naturally the big takeaway was you know
Optimus Prime on a dinosaur so if that
doesn't get you excited I don't know
what will so let's talk about some of
the most important parts of the movie so
it's not a reboot they're going to
acknowledge some of the things that
happened the last movie you know the
all-out Decepticon invasion but there is
a new villain there are some rumors
about who that villain is they haven't
officially released his name yet but
careful for potential spoilers if you
don't want to know so based on some of
the alternate design pictures we saw
last year during comic-con it's rumored
that it's going to be Nemesis Prime the
full cast of transformers includes of
course Optimus Prime on said dinosaur
bumblebee hound Grimlock lockdown
stinger and then there's a bunch of cars
that don't have names yet these include
both transformers and Decepticons
there's a new Chevy stingray a Bugatti
Veyron an old marmon cabover semi-truck
a silver Trump GE jet a white Camaro and
a black rally fighter the most notable
thing though is the human cast they've
been a bunch of changes since the last
movie vs mark wahlberg he's actually
playing a struggling inventor so he's
basically the protagonist of the film
Nicola Peltz is his daughter Jack reynor
is her boyfriend and kind of like the
new Sam Witwicky character he's a
racecar driver i would say dead to
rights that he's going to be the one
driving bumblebee kelsey Grammer's kind
of the human villain to the story he
works for the government Victoria summer
is his assistant Stanley Tucci is kind
of like an evil scientist trying to
build new weapons based on transformer
tech Sophia Myles is his assistant and
leave Bing Bing is the CEO of the
Chinese transformers or like the Chinese
version of the American transformers
organization the basic idea the plot
though is that stanley tucci kelsey
grammer and other you know pseudo evil
government people are trying to build
weapons based on transformer tech it
goes horribly wrong and a new villain
comes from space you know said
Decepticon so it's possible that nemesis
prime could either come from outer space
or he could be some of the horrible
consequences of you know whatever their
testing is there's also this crazy
Unicron rumor I haven't seen any
evidence to support that but it's
totally possible that he could be that
threat from space the thing that I'm
looking forward to most you know besides
robots on dinosaurs is then going to
China they filmed a lot of the movie in
China and obviously link beaming was a
really important casting for that but I
actually think that that's where we're
going to meet the Dinobots
cast in China let me know what you're
looking forward to most obviously we
don't know a whole lot about the plot
and this is kind of more of a teaser
trailer so hopefully this summer we'll
see a lot more footage so walking dead
is coming back next week be sure to
subscribe to get all my videos I'm going
to be doing some special countdown
videos this week it's gonna be a lot of
fun it's going to be super dark the
second half of this season also if you
didn't see I did a couple other Super
Bowl trailers they were really cool
click here for Captain America Winter
Soldier and click here for amazing
spider-man 2 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives